- Let's finish things
out with one last story
that may get your heart racing.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(Audience cheering)
Lots of people are into cooking shows.
and lots of people are
into dating shows as well.
So a news series has combined the two,
and it's called "Hotties", naturally,
which is streaming on Hulu.
Here you go.
- Rub the stuffing tube with
a bit of natural oil on-
- I know what that's like.
- Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Of course, of course you'd know.
- Look how cute, okay.
At first they weren't doing anything,
but I see there are
little flirtations now,
here and there.
Like they're giving each
other little looks like,
"Ooh, time to throw
some spice in the mix."
- All right.
- (beep)
Is it for a challenge?
Looks like we got our first challenge.
- [Laith] Right (moaning)
- (clapping) I don't wanna do it.
(Audience cheering)
- We have the host of "Hotties"
on the line right now.
You know her as a standup comedian
and former host of "The Soup."
Everybody say hello to Jade Catta-Preta.
(Audience cheering)
How you doing?
- Hi guys, how are you?
I'm such a fan, thank you for having me.
Oh, dinner, you're hilarious.
So, wait, how does this show work?
This is hilarious.
- So there's a lot.
It's, it's a hybrid dating,
cooking competition.
We have four sexy singles.
They go on two blind dates
and they have to cook the best dish
that they can come up with,
but there's a little bit of a twist.
Every 15 minutes we feed them
the spiciest stuff we can find,
and they have to get through that,
and get through the date
and get through the cooking competition.
And then whoever has the
best date, best dish or both,
wins 2,500 bucks for a second date.
However, another twist,
they can choose to take the money
and promise to never see each other again.
- (Audience member) Hey.
- Oh, well, that's kind
- It's very fun.
of a win-win.
You either get a date
or you get paid, yeah.
So the Spice Challenge,
it's the real kicker, right?
That's the thing that really gets people?
- Yeah, you know, they're
all, they're all cute.
They're looking cute, they're on a date.
And they're like I can
handle this tiny gummy bear,
but it's, you know 500,000
Scoville Heat Units.
And so they're crying,
their mascara's running,
they're jumping in the baby pool.
They're, they're chugging ranch, you know,
first date stuff.
- (laughing) They're chugging ranch.
I love that (laughing).
Well, thank you so much, Jade.
We're liking your post right now, right.
(Audience cheering)
- [Jade] Thank you.
- All right.
So remember you can see
"Hotties" streaming now on Hulu.
And usually this is the part of the show
when we give our guest a thousand dollars,
courtesy of our season long partner,
pilot Pen, makers of FriXion,
the go to a erasable pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show.
But today, we are spicing things up.
See what we did there?
And it's going to someone in our audience.
So look under your chair.
You might have a thousand
dollars under your chair.
(drum roll)
(exciting murmuring)
- (whooping joyously)
(Kelly whooping)
(Audience cheering)
(drum beats and cimbols clanging)
(Audience clapping)
(Kelly laughing)
- Oh my gosh.
What's, what's your name?
Where are you from?
- Hi, my name is Celia Durantez,
I'm actually visiting from Guam right now.
- Well, welcome and congratulations.
You get a thousand dollars.
(Audience cheering)
How, how are you gonna spend it?
Do you know?
- I don't know.
Probably do something with my husband.
He does a lot for me,
so I can give him some.
- Oh that's nice.
- Aww.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Well have fun
while you're visiting, okay?
- [Celia] Thank you Kelly (chuckles).
- Alright, alright.
Well thank you so much,
have so much fun with all that money.
And thank you to all our guests this hour,
Chloe Kardashian, Tyler
Jacob and Michael Ryan.
Y'all have a great day
and if it's not great,
well, time changer.
(Audience cheering)